ça vous est absolument me faire revenir
cette série vous savez
moi qui essayent de m'échapper de la
politique
rien
d'abord un je me garderai bien de faire
le moindre pronostic pour l'instant j'ai
vous avez rappelé que j'ai fait la
politique je me souviens que en février
1995 personne n'aurait parié sur la
victoire de jacques chirac je me
souviens que
giscard d'estaing quatre mois avant le
renouvellement de son mandat personne
n'imaginait qui pourrait être battu par
françois mitterrand nicolas sarkozy
samoa avant la fin son mandat personne
imaginez qu'ils ne puissent pas faire un
deuxième mandat pour vous tout est
possible dans cette élection je pense
que tout est possible aujourd'hui et le
fait que ce soit une femme qui
représente alors
je connais les journalistes politiques
très bien ainsi je viens pas la question
pour la question moi qui voulais parler
du théâtre et de ces femmes qui avaient
la france mais vous voulez dire que
pécresse va réveiller la france c'est ça
je pense que
il ya quelque chose ces appareils est
très intéressant aujourd'hui
c'est il ya très peu de périodes dans
notre histoire politique ou la société
politique n'a pas construit de
personnages évident on ne pouvait
compter c'est mitterrand mais il a
dominé la gauche on pouvait compter
c'est giscard mais là dominé à droite on
pouvait compter c'est chirac mais la
dominer n'avait pas besoin de faire de
primaire il s'imposait
or aujourd'hui plus personne ne s'impose
et
c'est révélateur de quoi pour vous
c'est révélateur de
même beaucoup je l'expliqué dans dans ce
livre sur l'humour
aujourd'hui le si cela la politique est
devenue un véritable métier du spectacle
zac on ne cherche pas à créer une
espérance a créé avoir un discours sur
les petites phrases pour être dues pour
que vous repreniez cette histoire est
donc on a asséché le discours politique
et
deuxièmement se trouve pardon parce que
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur console il
quand elle peut-il zehrir sur les
archives le niveau de culture d un
politique quand vous aviez un débat
entre jaurès et clemenceau quelle
culture quand vous aviez des discours de
jaurès médicaux de clemenceau d'arrêt si
brillant vous êtes impressionné quand
vous regardez et vous lisez aujourd'hui
lé discours
c 'est technocratique c'est à dire que
jadis
les parlementaires n'étaient pas entouré
de collaborateurs il improvisait il
avait des convictions il avait une
volonté aujourd'hui on ne trouve plus
cela mais c'est spécifique aux
politiques ou c'est le syndrome d'un
affaiblissement de l'école aujourd'hui
en france non mais moi je suis pas
compétent je constate simplement qu'il y
à une uniformisation dix courses je
prends j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur les
professions de foi il y a trente ans la
profession de foi du député au
dessinateur était très intéressant parce
que c'était lui qui l'a rédigé et donc
on voyait la personnalité de du candidat
aujourd'hui c'est le parti qui on voit
les professions de foi toutes faites et
vous prenez du lot-et-garonne à l'heure
en passant par l'allié la somme ce sont
les mêmes il rajoute leur nom en bas un
signal il n'y a plus cet enrichissement
de la diversité
[Musique]